Hello Freak bitches.
How did you,
this,
uh,
impression you're doing to this White House character?
What's his name again?
Stephen Miller.
How does,
first of all,
everyone's doing Sean Spicer or they weren't until he got fired or I'll,
I'll uh,
Scaramucci and two and Sean sweat.
Yeah.
Melissa McCarthy was doing Sean Spicer.
He killed it.
Yeah.
Was hilarious.
You know,
it's funny,
Trump thought that it made him look weak,
that a woman was doing an impression.
What would she go and do an impression of Trump now because of that?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
No,
I mean,
I don't know.
I mean I think that,
you know,
I did a special,
what was it?
I've been to like,
I think it was like 2012 for showtime called politics where I went to DC and I
did standup in DC and I interviewed all po.
I love politicians.
Like that's all I watch when I come home at night.
All I watch is CNN,
MSN,
and Fox just because that's it.
Cause I'm in shock and I can't believe it.
No,
I just go back and forth that there's so many fucked up things that are going on
in the world.
The whole North Korea thing is insane.
It's Gary.
It's fucking insane.
Well,
what's scary is
Donald Trump is saying shit like fire and fury that the world has never known.
Like Jesus Dude,
like this isn't a movie.
This is real life.
Yeah,
but I mean this North Korean guys fucking nuts.
He is fucking this fucking nuts.
It's like,
it's like dude,
stop shooting fucking missiles in the fucking,
this isn't like a play pen thing.
Do you just keep shooting missiles in the ocean all the time?
Like it's like he's like a kid or some shit and he can't,
it's just,
I don't know.
It's just a,
well I think Guam is only like 2000 miles away from North Korea or something
like real close.
So they're talking about him possibly bombing Guam and that's what they're
saying now I know I been watching it like a death sentence.
I mean if,
if we decided to attack North Korea,
it would be a death sentence to them.
And then also I heard,
cause I know,
I know Dennis Rodman,
you know,
I know Dennis,
do you,
did you talk to him when he went over there?
I know I don't want to get too too into it,
but I know that he goes over there a lot and he meets with Kim Jong.
Ooh.
They just fucking get drunk and I don't know,
they go on jet skis or some shit.
Like he like,
he like a,
um,
he likes Dennis Rodman,
so he brings them out.
But from what I heard is that Kim Jong Goon really loves Donald Trump.
Like,
you know what I mean?
Like his,
the American,
he loves America,
but he's like kind of acting like he doesn't love America.
Like he loves the American way at that picture.
Yeah.
So my point is,
is I think,
I really think that if Donald Trump went over there to meet with the guy,
I think that would appease him and just show him the fuck out.
I think that's just my opinion.
Maybe you should be like a liaison.
Yeah,
there you go.
But he gets,
he gets,
uh,
you know,
he goes over there and hangs out with them because they,
Kim Jong and kid loves,
loves.
Um,
I think he loves America.
Yeah.
He loves America.
And that's,
it's just kind of like a weird,
you know,
there's,
there's no,
um,
what's the word?
There's no,
uh,
I don't get a modification communication.
They're not communicating right.
You know.
Well,
there's language barrier obviously,
but isn't he young?
Isn't Kim Jong Un like in his thirties?
Hold Z.
Yeah,
he's pretty young.
It's,
I mean,
imagine running a military dictatorship in your thirties,
and he's already murdered a gang of people who are already in.
The thing that's so crazy about the whole thing is that like,
you think of Isis and you think of that whole,
you know how those people,
like they don't care to dot,
and they don't care if they're going to die.
And I think that he's trained his people,
all the cmec always on CNN,
all these marching soldiers.
I think those guys are ready to die.
Well,
if you lived in a shit hole like North Korea where every day you're under the
oppressive of a military dictatorship,
maybe you'd be ready to die too.
You're like,
it's either escape to South Korea or die.
You know,
I,
I think what what should happen is I think Trump should hire Dennis Rodman and
like put like a tracking device on them and their jet skiing out in fucking the
ocean drinking and shit and it's seal team six comes in and fucking takes Kim
Jong Goon and slides new America gives all the North Korean internet and like
sets them free.
No,
this is like a movie dude.
And that was Stephen Baldwin.
I think that there's probably a way to,
to,
to chill everything.
There probably is a way to shut everything out.
This is not the way,
like launching test missiles and saying fire and fury and all that shit.
Nah,
not,
not chilling anything out,
but you know,
I don't understand what the conflict is about in the first place.
I'm not exactly sure what everybody's angry,
but I think because they think that we're going to bomb them.
And why are we going to bomb them?
That's what I was,
I think that we did years ago.
Right?
They hear a,
the career,
well,
North Korea,
no,
Hiroshima was Japan.
The Asians.
I don't know the details,
but I know that there are different part of the world,
but that's cool.
They'll be super psyched.
Conflate the two of them.
Yeah,
no,
it's,
I'm mean the,
we did horrible things during the Korean War to the North Koreans.
I mean that's literally the cause of all of this.
All the anger and all the,
you know,
but that's when North Korea and South Korea were split and North Korea went
communists and you know,
it's a,
it's all a byproduct of that.
You know,
there's,
it's,
you could read about it and actually there's a really good book called dear
reader from Michael Malice.
He's a guy who was on my podcast and the history of that part of the world is
really fucked up.
But it's interesting because you have North Korea and then below you have South
Korea,
South Korea,
you have a thriving economy,
amazing electronics,
Samsung,
they make all kinds great shit over there.
And spaz probably,
yeah,
on plastic surgery.
Yeah.
And then North Korea is just right next door to them.
Terrible dictatorship.
It's fucked up man.
Well no president has been able to,
to deal with it,
so no.
Yeah,
probably won't be able to mean.
How do you resolve that?
One of the things that my mouse was telling me that makes it so fucked up is
that everybody has to rat on everybody else.
Like say if you and I were working together,
we wouldn't have to go somewhere and tell someone what each one of us did wrong
during the day.
Like maybe you didn't cry hard enough when somebody died or maybe you weren't a
excited enough when something good happened,
he didn't cheer loud enough and they'll,
they'll rat you out for that.
And then you know,
you have to be accountable and then so they have like a culture of rats.
Everybody's ratting everybody out.
It sounds fun.
We don't realize how lucky we are,
you know,
to live in America
[inaudible]
okay.